[Music]
okay so this is another renegade this is
a 2016 doing an oem key
and one thing that does scare the hell
out of me if you see these things around
the buttons they're bling rings
and they will interfere i did a video
with these before
but
we're gonna try it
i'm gonna choose jeep
we're going to go to
manual selection
i do have the four four ways on by the
way
north america
this is a renegade
see
15 to 17. it's a smart key
click yes
there is not but we are going to push
this button until it says no key fob
detected
okay we're gonna go to hot function
and do all smart keys lost guided
click start
okay
connection is off and the hazards are on
i'm just going to hit this button one
more time
just to keep things a little alive here
16184 but that saves it for us
okay
we're going to place this
right over here towards the button
we're going to hit
the unlock button one time
i am going to go a little bit closer
because of this stupid bling ring
racing failed
[Laughter]
okay we will go back through it and
click okay
no we don't need to re-read the pin code
all doors are closed
okay
place this right here near the start
stop button
unlock one time
[Laughter]
bracelet failed okay
all right so i'm going back in this i
took this stupid bling ring off this
thing
smart key
start
okay
[Laughter]
there we go
[Music]
this vehicle is done
and this was our problem this stupid
bling ring